Dr Zak are there any
other
compulsory fasts other than the month of
Ramadan that a Muslim must
observe the fast can be broadly
categorized into F the fast that
obligatory and the other is T fast that
the voluntary fast or the non obligatory
fast which inshallah we'll be dealing
maybe on the episode 31 as far as
obligatory fast are concerned
you can classify it under four types the
first as we discussing the obligatory
fast during the month of Ramadan the
second is if a person misses the fast of
Ramadan for any
reason cover up the fast M it's known as
kfast the third is fasting for
expiration of the sins if you committed
a sin and you have to fast give a kafar
that's the third type and the fourth is
fasting if you vow to fast so these are
basically the four types of f fasting
which are the
Islam